[Music]
hi I'm Jeff stun from the great race and
we're continuing our series of how-to
videos and today I'm going to talk to
you about how to start from a
standing start at the first sign of the
day on the great race now each car as
you know will be assigned uh a number
you draw a number the day before and
that's your start position and let's say
you start as number
27 and this start of the day I'm talking
about is not the start at the
hotel most days the start at the hotel
will be at 8:00 plus your start order so
in this example we're talking about
number
27 so an 8:00 start 8:27 then would be
your start time but you then we'll do
the tire warmup and the calibration
before the actual scoring starts for the
day there will be a sign that is
designated as the starting location for
every car for that day and if the start
time for example at that sign is
9:05 and we're car number
27 then our start time at that sign then
becomes
932 that's the start time of 9: 5 plus
27 positions which is 27 minutes for
start time of
9:32 now let's say the start Speed is 30
m an
hour obviously at that sign if you're
sitting at that sign and ready to go at
932 you cannot
instantaneously get from 0 to 30 mil an
hour now this goes back to your
performance chart that you you should
have done prior to coming to the great
rate
now as an example of how to make that
performance sharp just real
quickly all you have to do it back home
is find an OB two objects it could be
two telephone poles or two signs or two
cones you put out and you put those any
distance apart and let's say you've and
then you run each speed through those
signs let's let's call it telephone
po let's say back home that it took you
uh 35 seconds to run at 30 m hour
between those two telephone poles you
started your stopwatch at the first pole
you held 30 m an hour all the way
through and you clicked it off at the
second pole and that's 35
seconds now you go back at that same
speed and instead of driving straight
through those two poles you stop at the
first pole have your stopwatch ready you
tell the driver to go and as soon as he
goes you start the stopwatch
when you pass the second pole you stop
the stopwatch now a minute ago when you
drove straight through you did it in 35
seconds now starting from the
standstill let's say it took 38 seconds
what does that tell you that tells you
that it takes you 3 seconds to get to
speed from 30 m an
hour now let's fast forward back to
Great race day and we're starting at
this specific sign we're talking about
this the start of the day 9:05 start
time car number
27 9:32 is your start time and the start
speed's 30 m an
hour now we know it takes 3 seconds to
get from zero to to 30 m an hour so
we're going to start at that sign 3
seconds
early to make us on time so now we're
going to start at
9:31 and5 57 seconds what will happen is
the car in front of you will have left a
minute early before
you as soon as they leave you pull up to
that start sign with this with the clock
running telling the driver when I tell
when I do a countdown you're going to go
to 30 mil an hour and you're watching
your your clock and as it's 9:31 and 30
seconds you tell the driver all right
we're going to be going in about 25
seconds and you start to give them a
countdown and that countdown
should uh finish at
9:31 and 57 seconds so that you're
already going and at speed and on time
when 9:32 your actual start time
arrives now it's not as complicated as
all that sounds uh if you have any other
questions or any want more detail you
feel free to call me
at 800
98972 23 or you can email me at Jeff at
greatrace.com
[Music]
thanks